sure there's a chance jim carrey may don
the mask of loki again in the future but
if his demands aren't met could we see
another film without the legendary actor
in the starring role this is what it
would take to get jim carrey to star in
the mask again one of jim carrey's most
iconic roles from his early to mid 90s
movie star hot streak is stanley ipkis
the milk toast cartoon nut who gains
supernatural powers after donning an
enchanted mask in the comedy the mask
the part was perfect for carrie who has
always been something of a live-action
cartoon character on his own with the
aid of some extremely 90 special effects
he gets to literally become one in the
1994 film co-starring cameron diaz and
peter riegert today the mask remains one
of the most memorable titles in his
expansive filmography
[Music]
somebody stopped me
given that it's been almost three
decades since the mask debuted in
theaters it would also seem to be a
perfect fit for a sequel the original
movie is based on the dark horse comic
book series which is often a good
starting place and while there was a
2005 sequel to the movie son of the mask
starring jamie kennedy it fell short of
the live wire energy carrie brought to
the character the problem is that the
comedy legend has been seemingly averse
to the idea of reprising the role but in
an interview with comicbook.com to
promote his turn as dr robotnik in 2020
sonic the hedgehog carrie was asked
about the possibility of doing a second
installment of the mask and his answer
wasn't entirely negative at first he
shared his general apathy towards
sequels remarking
i don't think in terms of sequels and
stuff like that i mean this one sonic
the hedgehog is kind of right for it
because we have not evolved the
character fully yet carrie then went on
to express that his interest in doing
the mask too would depend on the
filmmaker involved explaining i don't
want to do it just to do it but i would
only do it if it was some crazy
visionary filmmaker if his answer sounds
familiar it mirrors a very similar
attitude carrie expressed about a sequel
to ace ventura in an april 2022
interview with e online he again said he
would only want to return to his iconic
character if a visionary filmmaker was
directing it only this time he named a
specific filmmaker christopher nolan
did you miss me
the 2005 sequel to the mask son of the
mask was met with an abysmal six percent
critics rating on rotten tomatoes
despite the poor showing the mask
creator mike richardson spoke with
forbes in 2019 about revisiting the
franchise albeit with a different person
donning the green mask richardson dished
i'd like to see a really good physical
comedian in the role i have one in mind
but i'm not gonna say her name we have
to do a lot of convincing for this
particular actor but we'll see you never
know what's coming in the future we have
some ideas richardson kept mum about who
the actress would be but there is
precedent in the dark horse comic series
for someone else to put on the mask in
the event carrie doesn't return for
example the hunt for green october
storyline from 1995 sees a young girl
named emily tuttle putting on the
artifact to gain its supernatural powers
in the process she gets back at some of
her schoolyard bullies the comics also
remind us that following stanley's death
lieutenant kelloway comes into
possession of the mask and uses it to
assist in his investigations
unfortunately the bewitched item takes a
toll on callaway and affects his
personal and professional life leading
him to put it away for good perhaps most
notably stanley's girlfriend kathy
becomes a prominent wearer of the mask
after she assassinates him while under
its spell with that said an adaptation
of the original comic continuation the
mask returns could work as a
hypothetical sequel though it would
probably need some reworking to fit as a
proper follow-up to the films in his
interview with forbes richardson went on
to elaborate one of the great things
about the mask is that anybody can get
it so you can do a story about anyone
and you could cast any comedian in the
role while someone else could certainly
lead a new mask movie no doubt fans
would love to see carrie back in the
part only time will tell who will become
the next mask in live action if it even
happens at all check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you